people are confused sometimes by exactly
who and what I am and that's because in
my personality which is a humbler word
than method two things are united which
are usually not found co-present my
techniques are all shamanic and involve
perturbing the senses and dissolving
ordinary states of mind through
psychedelics so my techniques are
shamanic but my my my would I call I
guess method not techniques but method
is rational and analytical so I use
shamanic techniques to go into shamanic
places and then attempt to study them
scientifically using reason saying what
is this how does it work what is it made
of what how do its parts relate to each
other and what is its inner dynamic and
I this apparently though it seems fairly
obvious to me is a fairly radical union
of techniques scientists don't explore
psychedelics because somehow the the
scientific mind must not be besmirched
by contact and contamination with the
thing studied but how the hell can you
study psychedelics without taking them
rats are not very satisfying and
graduate students still less so so
eventually you know you're going to have
to get your feet wet well then they say
well but that destroys your scientific
objectivity well not if it's the only
method the only path to contacting the
phenomenon that you're attempting to
study so that has worked for me I am NOT
part of the new age in my own mind to me
the new age is typify by an incredible
trudeau leti and in other immunity to
cognitive dissonance I mean you know you
can believe that the world is ruled from
the Pleiades and you can believe that l
ron Hubbard is God there seems to be no
end to the number of contradictions that
the New Age can simultaneously entertain
but what i have done is i probe
weirdness I am but rationally most
people who are attracted to weirdness
want to convert and believe it and take
it in and exalt it I don't I I don't
want to believe anything I hated e ology
all ideology that's what I why I'm so
casual about the possible crushing of my
own because ideologies are a lesser a
lesser resolution of our dilemma than we
are capable of the higher resolution
lies in real feeling and real community
and affection ideology has poisoned the
last thousand years
all of these ideologies have ultimately
done more good and done more bad than
good
Marxism Christianity even you know at
the risk of setting off a riot
Freudianism on and on and on the the
correct method I think is simply the
phenomenological approach catalog data
seek patterns draw conclusions test them
back against the original data now most
people who advocate that kind of an
approach somehow come down it brings
them down they say well this method then
shows you that being is only this and
thought is only the
and love is merely this and social in
other words it's a it reduces everything
it insults everything I haven't found
that to be the case I've found real
weirdness the world is strange
very very very strange not only I mean
far stranger than I suppose and orders
of magnitude more strange than these
cheerful workbench scientists and
keepers of the faith of our culture
suppose there are doorways there are
edges there are passageways but for
every real one there are 10000 dead ends
called the sacks and cheap scans of one
sort so to go out as an arching new into
the world seeking to invest your belief
in something you will be instantly
sucked into some screwy thing and your
life force pulled from you and you will
be used and abused as awning news and
naives
always are a much better approach is you
know be tough the truth does not require
your participation in order to exist
[ __ ] does but the truth is fine
thank you
whether you believe in it or not so what
is what is gained by the truth if you
believe in it nothing I maintain and and
you are diminished you are diminished
because by believing in something you
have precluded your freedom to believe
in its opposite you gave away the most
precious existential currency in the
universe so you know I think it's very
good to be tough to ask the hard
questions and but to to go a long way
down the path with these claim
to secret knowledge insight lineage but
ultimately you know the hard questions
have to be asked and this is not a path
toward dispelling the mystery from the
universe this is the way to get to the
real gold in a hurry not become
glamorized or subverted by the dross of
the world well maybe that's enough for
this evening we will go over all of
these things at the level of intensity
that you are interested in it's fine to
get down to the how much how and when
questions about the compounds and plants
that is technique and that's important
because it's fine to sit here talking
about the psychedelic experience this
bears no resemblance to the psychedelic
experience in any form whatsoever so
it's very important that you leave here
empowered empowered to make your way
into these places with confidence and
then the other thing to pay attention to
is inevitably the way our ass-backwards
society works is it creates cults of
personality and and Renaissance
stabilized points of focus on the
celebrity personality who is the teacher
the guy who wears the microphone or the
woman who wears the microphone what you
can really take away from here if you're
smart is community of some sort probably
someone in this room has what you need
and I guarantee you it isn't me so don't
waste your time on me but
that's all there for you to sort out so
techniques we can discuss the formation
of community and association is your own
business and then as much time as you
want to spend on the what is it all mean
mr. natural side of the question and
we'll dig into all of this to ten
o'clock tomorrow
thank you very much get some sleep or go
to the baths or do both or go to the Ray
[Music]
[Music]